good afternoon and thank you for coming
I'm superintendent Sally Riley I'm the
operations manager for Lancaster
Morecambe and wire
it's been a week now since Nicola bully
from Inskip in the local area went
missing
her family particularly her partner her
children
her parents and her sister
are in real Agony while she remains
missing and I want to pay a particular
tribute for their patience and dignity
and strength at this time
in the last seven days since Nicola went
missing a week ago today
the police have done a number of
inquiries to try and find Nicola and to
bring her home to a family
in particular the search is focused on
the riverbank and the river wire
here in St Michael's
an unprecedented number of search
resources have been searching the river
and the bank
this includes drone
the helicopter
police divers
sonar equipment
pole cameras
underwater drone
and staff wading the shallower parts of
the river
we've also had search dogs that are
specially trained in the area
from both the boat and the riverbank
and this is included the area where
Nicola went missing
but also Upstream of where she went
missing
and the 15 kilometers or so
down to the Sea
we've been assisted in this
by the Coast Guard
by rnli
thy colleagues from other forces
and the Lancaster area search and rescue
and I want to thank them for their
assistance
unfortunately we have not still found
Nicola
but our search does continue
as well as the river search we've also
undertaken a one kilometer
physical search of the open ground in a
radius from the point where she last
went missing
this has included open ground
empty buildings and their Gardens
to no avail so far
as well as search officers we've had a
number of uniform staff in the area
offices and pcsos receiving Community
intelligence
and offering that visible presence to
the local community to answer any
questions and to allay any concerns
at the same time a dedicated team of
investigators who often assist missing
people inquiries has been working on
this tirelessly
they have undertaken extensive house to
house inquiries
they've checked numerous CCTV dash cam
and ring doorbell footage
they've traced and now spoken to a
number of key Witnesses
they have
spoken to people in the community who
have information
about nichola's lifestyle her daily walk
walks and so on
all this has built up a really rich
picture of data that's allowed us
to have a very tight timeline
some details of which we've already
released
about Nicola's last whereabouts
and what she was doing last Friday
morning
I'm just going to take you through some
of those
so at 8 43 last Friday Nicola was seen
on the river path walking towards the
Iron Bridge
a few minutes later at 8 47 she was seen
in the lower field with her dog Willow
and her mobile phone which was on view
at 8 53 she sent an email to her boss on
her phone
and at 901 she joined a team's work call
all of this was normal behavior for
Nicola
this was not out of the ordinary and
nothing different or unusual happened
during those calls and emails
at 9 10 she was seen in the upper field
the dog was off the lead again this was
normal
the dog was not in its harness and the
lead wasn't on the dog which was all
part of nichola's daily routine
at 9 20
through inquiries we've made we believe
that her phone was on the bench
at 9 30 the team's meeting ended but
Nicola's phone remained dialed in
at 9 33
a witness found Nicholas dog Willow
running between the gates to the field
and the bench where the phone was
located
also found by that witness was the dog
harness which was on the grass between
the bench and The River's Edge
therefore the time
that we are particularly interested in
is between 9 10
the last confirmed sighting
and at 9 20 when Nicola's phone was
found on the bench
sorry not found on the bench when
Nicholas phone was on the bench believed
to be on the bench found at around 9 33.
the witness made numerous inquiries to
try and find the owner of the phone not
knowing who whose phone it was and
indeed whose dog it was
that led the witness to meet up with
other people who did recognize the dog
as Nicholas
and the school to which uh Nicholas
children go was alerted at 10 50 as was
her family
this means that we've only a 10 minute
window
in which we cannot account for Nicola's
movements
the inquiry team has undertaken a number
as I said of dash cam and CCTV and ring
doorbell footages
this has allowed us to eliminate
any Trace so far of Nicola having left
the Riverside which is really important
so we believe that Nicola was in the
Riverside area and remained in the
Riverside area
we remain open to any inquiries that
might lead us to question that but at
this time
we understand
that she was by the river
our main working hypothesis therefore
is that Nicola has sadly fallen into the
river
that there is no third party or criminal
involvement
and that this is not suspicious but a
tragic case of a missing person
this is particularly important because
speculation otherwise
can be really distressing for the family
and for Nicholas children
in terms of what we would like from the
public
I would like to thank them particularly
Nicola's friends neighbors and the
community of Saint Michael's in The
Wider area who've come out in force to
help in the search for Nicola
I do have an update on the clothing that
Nicola was last seen wearing
and this is something that the public
who live in the area or who walk their
dogs on the river path
near to St Michael's or Downstream of St
Michael's towards morecon Bay can look
out for
they are an ankle length black quilted
Julie jacket
a black Engelbert Strauss waist length
coat which was worn underneath the Julie
tight fitting black jeans
long green walking socks tucked into her
jeans
ankle length green next Wellies
and a necklace and a pale blue Fitbit
it's really important that the public
pay heed to those very specific clothing
descriptions please
because factual sightings of those items
would be very useful to us
we also appeal for any remaining dash
cam
footage that may not yet have been
submitted to the police in this inquiry
particularly if people have that
relating to the garstang Lane area of St
Michael's
please can the public continue to report
only factual information that they have
and not speculation as to what may have
happened to Nicola because this is a
distraction to the police inquiry and
not helpful for the family
I would also appeal to the public to
keep themselves safe in this inquiry
people going out at night in the
darkness could fall into the river
and face all the hazards
likewise if they go out in boats on the
river please only do so if you've got
experience in doing that
we don't want people to be in danger
lastly I'd like to
underline the support given to the
family
it is as I've said an agonizing time for
them
Nicola has two little girls a partner
sister and parents
as well as many many friends and
neighbors and well wishers in the local
community
we are supporting her family with
specially trained officers and staff
and I'd like to thank the wider
Community for all the support that
they've given during this very difficult
inquiry
thank you
I'm happy to take questions if there are
any
questions
using the phone
yeah all the telephony and digital
inquiries have been handled by the
inquiry team so all of that data will be
looked at
thank you
research in the room after signs that
yeah did you find anything is there
anything support about high quality no
not so far unfortunately not that's why
I particularly appeal around any
clothing but maybe matting the
description I've given and it could be
found but nothing has been found in the
river
I should say that the river is tidal
below the Weir so if you see
um repeated searches of particular areas
of the river it's not necessarily
because we found something of note it's
because the river movement is complex
and we are taking advice from academic
specialists in water movement around
currents and so on just one other thing
has she made any contributions on the
team's call and she's spoken or was it
just on you not that I understand no and
again this was normal it was a large
team's call she was one of many people
on the call and I wouldn't have expected
to necessarily to participate actively
thank you
through telephony inquiries that we've
done relative to the phone itself rather
than through a witness
no okay hi hi
today obviously lots of friends
any new information
not that I'm aware of today clearly the
public are very well intentioned and
have given us a lot of information quite
rightly they don't know whether it is of
particular use or not and obviously we
can judge that can't we but
um so far it's taken a lot of effort and
diligence to go through all the
information that's been provided and and
we'll continue to do that right through
the weekend and into next week
can you tell us a bit about how many
calls or pieces of information you've
had from them to the Republican
I can't give you a number but I know
there's been a lot of calls today
clearly seven days on is a really good
time for people to think back
particularly if they have perhaps a
particular work pattern where maybe they
might be working on a Friday or not
working on a Friday it's again Friday
today and that will probably take them
back to what they were doing last Friday
were they driving through St Michael's
at around 9 15 were they dropping
children off were they going off to work
what were they doing last Friday that
they might always do that that would be
helpful for us to know if it's relevant
to the inquiry
yeah several of the exits from the
Riverside area are either locked or
they're covered by CCTV so we've been
able to look at that CCTV negate Nicola
leaving the local area the areas that
are not covered by CCTV is where we've
been particularly interested in dash cam
footage so that's garstang Lane leading
to the a586 if we can definitively cover
off that 10 minute window in particular
and the few minutes either side then we
will know definitively that she has not
left the area because of the lack of
footage or footage showing that she
didn't pass by but we are as sure as we
can be that Nicola did not leave the
area
no no no all the exits to the area that
she was as I say are either locked
covered by CCTV or garstangeline were
appealing for dashcam footage to cover
that Gap
in the river
s
at the point where the bench is located
there is quite a steep drop to the river
albeit not high it is steep and
therefore whilst I don't want to
speculate as to what may have happened
it is our working hypothesis that she's
entered the water accidentally
and and that's why there is no further
physical evidence on the field
she comes from yes
it's different depths actually which is
why we've had some stuff wading the
river and some staff uh underwater
search but as I say the sheer number
actually an unprecedented amount of
technical equipment with the sonars the
pole cameras the dogs uh the surface
searches the underwater search it is
really so very thorough
um that that we have discounted uh
finding anything in that immediate area
under underwater factors
um
we're not considering we've clearly
considered
um the whole picture but that is not
relevant at this time no not at all
correct so Nicola was last seen by a
witness at 9 10 and the phone was back
on the bench at 9 20 or thereabouts yes
all of the timeline details what the
police have been doing every day uh what
we're intending to do over the next few
days is all relayed to the family so
that they kept updated and are aware
yeah foreign
the dog was off the lead this was normal
for the dog to run about and Nicola was
on a team's call which again it would be
normal for her not necessarily to
participate in actively and just to have
the phone to listen in effectively
you do you do but anything could have
happened with the dog whereby Nicola may
have gone and I don't wish to speculate
in that we don't know but it is possible
as the dog was loosen off the lead that
there may have been an issue with the
dog that led her to go near to the
water's edge she puts the phone down to
go and deal with the dog momentarily and
and Nicola may have fallen in so that is
a possibility
the dog was dry yes
seems normal yes
we don't believe the dog was in the
river because the dog we believe was dry
and the witnesses who uh who are part of
the timeline that I've laid out have not
described the dog for example swimming
in the river or jumping into the river
so we assumed the dog didn't get into
the river but we don't know why Nicola
may have entered the water if she did
is in terms of search operations well
clearly
um a 15 kilometer stretch of river is is
long and therefore
um you know our partners continue to
assist us in that so there are lots of
things that we'll be doing over the
weekend in terms of
um water surface and Riverbank searching
and our partners will be working with us
into next week but it's too too early to
say at this stage how long it will be
I'm going to take one more question if I
made from someone who hasn't yet
answered asked a question thank you
this is a large rural area with a long
stretch of river
all I can say is that we are doing
absolutely everything possible we are
working tirelessly long hours with a
very large team of both plain clothes
and specialist uniformed officers
to try and do everything we can to bring
Nicola home
to her family but it is a very complex
and challenging situation and we hope
for a good outcome
quite limited small
well as each day goes on we become very
much more concerned for Nicholas safety
but uh we have the best minds and the
best trained officers available to us as
well as a number of very specialist
Partners so every potential
um possible way of improving our chances
of finding Nicola are being exploited
thank you okay